[Música]
olá meu nome é joão pedro tem 10 anos e
se o aluno do 5º ano e hoje vim fazer
uma pergunta muito dos convidados aqui
tem filhos
levante a mão quem os filhos brinca
quatro áreas ao ar livre por dia três
horas duas horas e uma pesquisa
descobriu que 84% das crianças
brasileiras
brincam somente até duas horas ao ar
livre
isso é preocupante se pensarmos que um
presidiário segurança máxima americano
tem garantido o seu tempo mínimo ao sol
de duas horas
outra pergunta vocês sabiam que a dança
do futuro tem crescido muito pois é a
depressão tem crescido muito eo
principal motivo dela é o stress que
você deve estar se perguntando o que a
primeira pergunta tem a ver com a
segunda e hoje eu vim fazer um alerta
existem crianças com a agenda estão
lotadas que não têm tempo para fazer
algo que é fundamental a brincar
alguns pais não levem importância
brincar como tem que ter pois tem um dia
muito corrido e não têm com quem deixar
os filhos e outros porque acham que seus
filhos têm que estar preparados para o
mercado competitivo então com eles em
excesso de atividades
eu vou contar para vocês o que aprende
brincando atenção e autocontrole
com o tempo fui aprendendo até ter mais
atenção e controle porque errava e
ficava muito estressado planejamento
sempre quis fazer coisas cada vez mais
difíceis e planejava cada etapa do que
ser executado criatividade você precisa
mesmo do que vai levar você pode fazer
como quando fui num parque e fiz uma
casa e quando estava em casa brinca fez
uma banda de panela humildade quando
você pede ajuda e se não te faz uma
criança mais adulto
o que importa é que você conseguiu pedir
ajuda
para fazer o que queria a pesquisa nas
crianças somos muito curiosas e sempre
queremos saber de tudo que aprendi muita
coisa brincando trabalho em equipe
com o tempo você aprende a dividir seu
espaço dar sua opinião e ouvir a opinião
dos outros e isso é o trabalho em equipe
e assim você consegue ir mais longe com
os seus trabalhos
superação sempre fui muito aventureiro e
que saber o que tinha no céu embaixo da
água
superando o limite do meu corpo coragem
superei meus medos brincando como com
giz de cera 2 na vela e tentei e obscuro
brinque de gato mia entre outras
brincadeiras preservação da natureza
preserva a natureza não porque ele
livros mas porque brinquei muito com ela
e nunca imaginei que ele vai jogar só da
barrenta seria tão bonito reciclagem
você já parou para pensar que vai virar
lixo tem como ser reciclado brincando
depois de brincar com essa caixa de
papelão vi que isso pode ser feito
empatia depois de experimentar um pouco
da sensação de soldado a palavra passou
a ter mais coisa para mim
respeito à diversidade em as viagens e
passeios não ficava preocupado para
saber se nós éramos iguais ou diferentes
queria saber sobre a cultura deles
ensinar a minha também
peters deus tenho muita sorte de nascer
com cinco bisavós e quatro avós muito
legais e com eles aprendem e ensinam
muito também
então viram o que é possível aprender
brincando e também é possível é também
dá pra aprender com a tecnologia como
smartphones tablets videogames entre
outros com com jogos de estratégia
programação criatividade entre outros
mas se não pode ter um tempo exagerado
senão você perde as coisas boas que dá
pra fazer o ar livre
então eu quero que vocês me ajudem a
levar essa mensagem para todos para que
nós tenhamos uma sociedade mais saudável
e feliz que criança precisa brincar
obrigado
[Aplausos]